how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have not just a leaked photos
from the set of the Eternals but a
leaked video as well we have a leaked
video of Susie flying through the air in
normal clothes not in internals outfit
and we have leaked photos of Kit
Harington as Black Knight and jemmye
channa Susie and the first time we are
seeing their relationship and also in
this video it looks like something is
actually grabbing her and taking control
of her and it's most likely a celestial
now these are the two main characters of
the movie Dane Wittman who is Black
Knight who was just a normal human with
the exception of being incredibly smart
and having a slight magical sense and
then sayers a who of course is an
eternal now at one point in time in the
comics Black Knight and Suzy are both
members of the Avengers and they're in a
relationship with each other
however Suzy is not supposed to be in a
relationship with the Dane because he's
a human and she's an eternal her job is
to watch over earth and watch over the
human population however in the comics
there's a is known to be quite the rebel
and is kind of unstable so she kind of
does what she wants for example in these
photos she's with Black Knight now just
based off of these photos that we see
here it's really hard to tell if he
actually knows that she's an eternal or
if she's pretending to be just a normal
human however we have a leaked video of
her flying away
[Music]
now if you notice in the very beginning
of this video there's a loud noise and
the people behind her in the left side
of the video all fall to the ground
however they soon get up and Susy takes
off into the air but it doesn't look
like she's doing this on her own if you
look at her it almost looks like
something is grabbing her using some
type of magical ability and bringing her
up into the sky this could be another
eternal that's mad at her for doing
something with the humans or this could
perhaps be a celestial we know that the
Celestials are going to be in the
Eternals this is already confirmed and
we have two pieces of concept art for
them and they would have the power to
push the people behind her down and to
bring her up into the sky or wherever
they may be taking her because if she
was flying away it would probably look
much different it would probably be
faster and look at the way her arms and
her legs are it looks like something is
controlling her and almost holding her
in this position so I'm going to say
that since Sayers he is such a rebel and
does things a lot that she's not
supposed to do when we know that the
Celestials are going to be in this movie
I'm gonna say that this is a celestial
grabbing her for some reason
she's done something and it's made them
mad so it's time to have a little chat
with her it could be another eternal but
as far as we're concerned none of the
Eternals have the power to do that to
control somebody that way
she could be flying but I assume it
would look very very different than this
and she would be moving at a much faster
speed but let me know what you think
about this do you think that she's being
captured by something probably a
celestial or do you think that she's
just flying and it looks kind of weird
because there's no CGI or anything yet
let me know what you think is happening
in this scene down below and let me know
what you think about Black Knight and
Suzy's relationship also don't forget to
leave a like on the video and subscribe
with notifications turned on so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff
you